und wir sind auch nicht so exponiert wie
meinetwegen bangladesch können auch
nicht so gut wie beim nur durch
[Musik]
von wann bis wann waren sie den
umweltministerin
ich bin umweltministerin seit knapp drei
jahren und ich werde es jedenfalls bis
zum ende dieser legislaturperiode wohl
bleiben so gott will wie man in dem
zusammenhang gesagt dass sie im amt sind
merkt man nicht so gerade woran liegt
das
auch das wundert mich dass sie das nicht
wahrnehmen die meisten annehmen zwar
braucht es wirklich jedes tier ja ich
bin sicher dass es jedes jahr und jedes
und jede pflanze ein eigenes lebensrecht
hat wespen ja wer ich bin schon lästig
das ist schon richtig aber sie ernähren
zum beispiel auch wieder vögel die
lassen sich von denen nicht schlecht
wieder an uns wieder aufs auto kacke
aber ja gut aber ich meine ein bisschen
paar reinigungsmittel muss ja auch
verkauft werden sollte auch die kinder
sich kümmern selbstverständlich das ist
eine generationenaufgabe wir haben
erstens die technischen möglichkeiten
und auch die finanziellen möglichkeiten
und wir sind auch nicht so exponiert wie
meinetwegen bangladesch könne auch nicht
so gut gehen wie bei mir durch sehr
nervt bei den klimaschutz plan am
meisten
also nerven tun diejenigen die die
chancen nicht erkennen
ich habe wirklich den ansatz der sagt
lasst uns rechtzeitig um steuern denn
wir werden so oder so umsteuern müssen
sehr interessant ich habe bei der frage
mehr notiert dass sie dann
wahrscheinlich antworten dass man das so
gar nicht sagen kann und jetzt haben sie
ja eigentlich ganz viel gesagt und jetzt
kann ich gar nicht dass danach würde ich
dann sagen dass die vier ministerien
sich alle einig sind wer am meisten
nerven nämlich barbara hendricks und
dann das
bereits haben sehen wir das verbockt ok
dann hab ich gleich konkret gefragt wer
trägt denn die schuld daran dass es noch
keine verbindliche festgeschriebenen
zahlen gibt in diesen klimaschutzplan
das kann man so nicht sagen wir sind ja
dabei das zu erörtern
es ist zum beispiel so dass die
landwirtschaft und der objektiven
gesichtspunkten gar nicht klimagas
neutral wirtschaften kann wollen sie
noch jemanden grüßen oder sich von den
eisbären
ich verabschiede mich nicht von den
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
last ich hab die schnauze voll los lasst
ein abo da